[Musique]
elle est ukrainienne il est russe le
couple de pianiste est à Montréal depuis
la millou ils ont dû mettre de côté la
musique le temps de quitter leur ville
Moscou
leur carrière et leur école de musique
rayonnaient à l'international leur lien
avec l'étranger les placaient dans une
position insoutenable depuis l'invasion
russe en Ukraine
ils ont pu obtenir des visas dans le
cadre du programme d'accueil canadien
leur décision de partir a été prise
avant la mobilisation qui aurait pu
mener Maxime au front
imposé au fil des contacts il y a une
solidarité entre musiciens mécène et
mélomane rencontré par hasard Serge
Gervois Weber et sa conjointe ce sont
liés d'amitié avec Olga coudriacova et
Maxime chateline ce sont des gens
vraiment remarquables remarquables
intéressante débrouillard
courageuse ont déjà compris la dynamique
au Québec ils se sont mis aux Français
tout en suivant les cours de français
Olga a déniché un piano d'occasion pour
recommencer à jouer
elle a aussi trouvé un local et du
financement pour offrir des cours de
piano à des élèves arrivés du crâne
depuis le printemps dernier
j'adore la musique c'est comment en
partie de ma vie très grand et très très
important pour moi
tous partagent le fait d'avoir laissé
derrière eux leur famille leurs amis
leur ancienne vie
dans leur bagages quelques souvenirs et
leur immense talent
ce sont des pianistes reconnus
ils ont gagné des concours
internationaux en duo et en solo et
espèrent renouer avec la scène ici
maxime chattalkin a d'ailleurs eu
l'occasion de le faire c'est automne
avec 4 semaines de préavis il a pris
tout un programme pour un concert avec
le trio Fibonacci
ils ont en eux la musique ce langage
universel
que la musique le transporte dans un
autre temps cette fois la musique et la
vie l'ont transporté ailleurs un nouvel
endroit qui la prévoit avec Olga
[Musique]